[Music]
we reporters and [ __ ] Oh getting
reporters this is my first time going to
prom at first I was like really for prom
back when I was like in the closet oh
it's the chance to like dance with a
nice girl but then like others I
realized my sexuality I started feeling
as though problem was it really for me
but now that I'm getting close to clear
from October like promise for everybody
and I'm really like excited to get out
there and dance
this is the first problems that have
ever been to and relax I have never been
to a prom because my junior year I had a
lot of financial troubles and even if I
had gone to prom oh not about at the
time my school is not very accepting I
just got to come in and not feel like
the odd one out I'm queer and it's like
good thing we come from white suburbia
Massachusetts so coming here and being
an all queer prom it's definitely
different from our past experience I
don't feel like I stand out I feel like
my outfit right now is giving me all of
the curves that I could ask for I feel
like I definitely slayed the red carpet
this one is very like open and very free
and like everyone's beating themselves
and it's just amazing to watch this prom
feels a ton gayer than all of my other
proms in a good way I think I'm really
excited to get to meet more people here
and to have a fun night with
[Music]
[Applause]
in Ascension
[Music]
[Applause]
so thank you so much for coming
you're beautiful beautiful crowd and I
wanted to give a special thanks to all
the high school students who came I want
to really highlight who this night is
about not only the high school students
but we have a very special prom chords
including you Lee yep and you have soon
come up come up on the stage now you
know every problem has to have a king or
queen so can we get Adam Lambert to the
stage
thank you you guys are I think I'm
supposed to give crowns to people
yeah so we have a comp in here mr.
Christopher it feels amazing like I
didn't expect for me to be prompted I
never like expected I would get to be
one ever in my life
next we have mr. prompt King row win yes
[Applause]
Amy a crown soon prom queen and prom
opsins prom queen wife win in the town
that we grew up and there definitely
wasn't a lot of support there definitely
wasn't a lot of exposure to LGBT here we
are in LA a place that I never imagined
that we'd be just know that you aren't
alone know that there are other people
out there we've made it this far we are
saved and painted even if you didn't get
invited to come to BuzzFeed's prom
you should still know that there's
people in your area that are really
ready to support and accept you and
you'll feel just as loved as we do right
now hailing all the way from South
Africa mr. B let's get over
and finally otter I want to tell all the
queer kids on the trans kids that are at
home and are not able to come to this
that your time is coming and once you
tell yourself that you know who you are
and no one can take that from you no one
can touch you ladies and gentlemen this
is your 2017 you must be queer prom
courts even when you're feeling alone
remember this feeling and remember the
people that are here today and remember
your family because we're always there
with you and you're never alone just
still be yourself be you be true to
yourself and shine as bright this all up
with colors and around stain soon
because there might be a little bit of
surprise because it can't be queer if
there isn't true
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've never seen any type of drag in real
life so seeing one IRL was like the best
feeling ever
I think the first one that came out was
like suit like splits or like gymnastic
type performer and items all over the
place so it was like super like
daredevil a she had something to say for
me to be like live front row seeing
Jasmine masters just twirl and do death
drops and backflips whatever right in
front of me it was it was like I was
watching her lip sync for her life
you have won the drag performance I mean
I had never done anything like that like
being able to be there and like feel the
emotions off of them unto us was just
fantastic can't nobody do you like you
can do you
[Applause]
I love the drag show it was amazing
even as the drag me just like walked in
a circle for like 10 minutes I didn't
care
that's one thing I can say about a drag
show is you will never leave board I
have never seen you know we've never
seen drag queens so I was like oh yeah
put a little expand she was like stage
close your mouth you are all beautiful
go bodies are you different tonight with
ending it will Shore just like all my
I'm sad that it's ending but like at the
same time it's like I glad I'm glad it
happened there's a mixed feeling when
the prom is starting to end because
we're like okay cool I'm tired I'm
hungry but then you also like I'm never
gonna be surrounded ever again
[Applause]
[Music]
well they played our like favorite slow
song right now and it was nice to be
able to dance cuz like we don't dance
that much at ours just because it's so
much like grinding so we don't we're
usually just like sit watch even just
like alone even though everybody's eyes
were on us it felt like it was below
just us you know and it was really nice
to be together and to be really close to
you come in so I mean I really like what
just happened but it was like the most
lesbian thing I've ever seen but in the
best way possible please thank the
beautiful wonderful parents I think we
got the best in the night and just be
super weird yeah
[Applause]
it went by so quickly so just like for
it to end it was like oh no like this is
coming to an end but it's also I was
still really like in shock and still an
all with love just being there
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're here at the Abbey in West
Hollywood it's the morning after the
career prom it was very fun it was very
surprising I was like wow it like
exceeded my expectations of like what an
American dream prom would look like
having gone through this experience
definitely boosted my confidence and
made me feel more like me that's growth
within you within your experience like
it's just really good to see you
confident
I kept capturing the good look on
Christopher's face and he was in heaven
I'm so grateful that his first
experience was such a supportive
community as a mother we don't want any
of the experience especially the initial
one to be traumatic or disappointing
every you said you're gonna make him
give me real hugs I love you okay I tend
to call Roland my shadow so it's very
like where I go rowan goes very quiet
doesn't really talk to folks much rowan
dancing at the prom last night and
interacting with folks was really really
different like and still shocking i'm so
proud of you it was kind of like a
freedom to be yourself sometimes as as
people we use our eyes to judge people
rather than getting to know them and
understand them I think it's taught me
to not use my eyes that use my heart I
don't know if there's anything she
doesn't know I love her more than
anything in the world so it didn't
become a queer prom it became a prom of
people that didn't care who everybody
else was I just love you thanks for you
know like supporting me no matter
you know and like people in the family
like thanks for just you don't be in
there for me what kind of sets like all
to our own respective hometowns and
stuff like that but like I know I have
lifelong friends you know and I can't
wait to see them again someday
I quit from I just saw all of these
queer and trans people who were really
successful and happy and fulfilled with
their lives even though they had been
through terrible stuffs like me they
still ended up happy and I'm gonna take
away that I also deserve that I also
deserve to be happy I just didn't expect
everyone to be so down to earth and
human I feel like I've known everyone
for like my whole life it feels like a
family right before I came to the queer
prom I was supposed to go get my name
change to town hall and then now I'm
going home and in the coming weeks I'm
hoping to start not only on HRT but to
start officiating the name change I am
cleaning this video and by the time this
comes out I will officially legally be
20 these videos are really important and
I feel like these kids are coming out
with different backgrounds and learning
to interact with different people and
learning more about themselves in the
process like I think I was educated more
than I educated other people don't be
afraid to take that first step for
advocacy in your own school or in your
own town and don't be afraid to put
yourself out there with the BuzzFeed
people in the prom court and everyone we
were just all so close knit is like such
a community we're all leaving today and
every surprise ever be that's we're like
goes through the same kind of stuff and
that we have each other no matter where
we come from I think the one thing that
I'm gonna take away from queer prom this
year was that I'm normal
that's such a new list
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]